ne
[Müzik]
duyduysan
[Alkış]
Yalnız burası çok heyecanlı Ya ben
şey yapamayacağım galiba
bu Vallahi yapamayacağım
Ya kusura bakmayın Osman Bey gerçekten
ben buranın böyle oldu bilmiyorum Ya
gerçekten ben deseydim Hepiniz çok
üzüleceksiniz değil mi Bileceksiniz
Yazık ya kız o kadar hazırlanmış gelmiş
süslenmiş püslenmiş Bir de psikolog
olmuş gelmiş heyecanlandı Burada da
heyecanı Evet bastırmaya çalışsaydım
Heyecanımı Aynı bu şekilde olacaktı seni
arıyorum ama ben Heyecanımı da buradayım
demek için geldim Hoş geldiniz
Bugün bir meslektaşıma programına davet
ettim aynı zamanda yapımcısı ve sunucusu
yuva programı program başladığımda
hocaya sordum hocam nasılsın dedim iyi
ama biraz heyecanlıyım dedi Ben dedim ki
merak etme Birazdan Heyecanın geçer
herkes de ilk başta öyle oluyor o hoca
dedi ki hayır ben böyle iyiyim heyecanım
kalsın isterim dedi Ben de dedim ki
Hocam heyecan iyi bir şey değil geçse
daha iyi hissetmezsin k Ya hayır bu
program Benim için değerli Sen benim
için değerlisin O yüzden heyecanlıyım ve
böyle kalsın istiyorum dedi ilk Hedef
konuşmacı teklifi geldiğinde kabul ettim
ancak daha sonra vazgeçmeyi çok düşündüm
dedim ki ya İnsanlar beğenmezler seyo
konuşmama onları yeterince etkili
yemezsem diye vazgeçmeyi çok düşündüm
Siz heyecandan sesim titreye bilir
konuşacaklarım unutabilirim Çünkü burası
benim için çok değerli Sizler benim için
çok değerlisiniz biliyor musunuz bu
kırmızı daire benim en büyük hayalim de
ve şu an Sizin karşınızda bunu
gerçekleştiriyorum Babam daha ben
üniversite sınavına hazırlanırken bana
bir kitap hediye etmişti adı TED gibi
konuş düşünün Ne zamandır burada olmayı
hayal ediyorum
Bu konuşmanın mükemmel bir konuşma
olması gerekmiyor ancak mükemmel bir
etki bırakması gerekiyor Bunu da Ancak
şu şekilde başarabileceğimi düşünüyorum
Eğer aranızdan bir o bile hayatında
Ruhunda kalbinde bir yerlere dokunup
Evet BİM'in Ben de orada olabilirim Bir
gün ben de o sahnede olabilirim hissini
verebilir Sem Amacıma ulaşmış Imm
demektir bir iş hayatında kasiyer olarak
başladım ben evet bildiğiniz AVM'de kası
yerdim daha sonra ekonomi okudum
ekonomiden Sonra mutlu olmadım Muhabir
olmak istediğime karar verdim
gazetecilik eğitimi aldı ve Ankara'ya
gittim Ankara'da özel bir kanalda bir
süre çalıştıktan sonra yine mutlu olmalı
ve Antalya'ya geri döndüm ne yapsam da
içimdeki şu yetersizlik duygusu artık
bir kurtulsam bir geçse diye düşünürken
Annem bugün dedi ki kızım sen psikolog
ol Sana dedim tamam Onu da dediğim Neden
olmasın Hani denemediğim bir o kalmıştı
hemen araştırdım Psikologlar ne iş yapar
nerelerde çalışırlar ömrümün sonuna
kadar yapabileceğim meslek bu mu diye
baktım Tamam yapabilirim bir anlık deli
cesaretiyle girdim sınava psikolojik
kazandım o araba yetişebilmek için de
Okulu üç yılda bitirdim şimdi
soracaksınız içindeki yetersizlik
duygusu gitti mi diye gitmedi hala
içimde bir yerlerde o duygu var şimdi
TED konuşması teklifi geldiğinde baktım
ki psikoloji biliminin duayenleri
felsefe biliminin duayenleri şöyle ünlü
böyle ünlü E ben Hoş geldin yetersizlik
duygusu oldum hayatta hepimizin
döngüleri var yaşam döngüleri dediğimiz
bu döngülerin dışına terapi dışarısında
çıkmak pek mümkün olmaz Türkiye'de TRT
herkese nasip olmuyor biliyorsunuz
çocukluğunda şiddet görmüş bir kişi
yetişkinliğinde de şiddet ortamı ister
Ya kendisi uygular ya da kendisine
uyguladığı şiddeti Çünkü beynin alıştığı
ortam budur kötü bile olsa beyin her
zaman alıştığını ister sevgi dolu bir
ailede büyümüş bir çocuksa ev Evet şimdi
sevgi dolu bir ortam hayal eder vardır
etrafınızda Aman Ali Rıza Bey huzurumuz
bozulmasın Ağzımızın tadı kaçmasın diye
diye Sonunda adama kalp krizi geçirenler
yok mu
evlendiğimiz kişi seçtiğimiz meslek
hepsi ama hepsi birtakım duygularımızdan
Kaçmak için yaptığımız seçimler Çünkü
değersizlik başarısızlık yetersizlik
duyguları kişiye o kadar ağır gelir ki
vücut bir süre sonra sinyal vermeye
başlar kötü olumsuz bir durum
yaşadığınızda bir anda böyle bir
kalbimizde bir çıkar pıntı başlar aynı
zamanda soğuk oldu da bir uyuşma Ne
tesadüf sırtladı bir terleme ve dersin
ki Eva kalp krizi geçiriyorum Ben ne
yapacağım hemen gidersin bir acil Ee
hediye çektirsin Allah'ım kalp krizi
geçiriyorum doktor bakar hayırsız kalp
krizi geçirme yorsunuz panik atak
geçiriyorsunuz Oh değersiz bir rahat
nefes alırsınız ya da farklı bir somatik
belirtiler olurdu Evet hızlı bir anda
ağrı girer ders-2 Allah Allah durduk
yere Benim başım Niye aradı hiç de
ağrımaz hemen bir Google'a yazarsanız
durduk yere Baş neden ağrır karşınızda
da böyle bir liste çıkar kesin
beyninizde tümör vardır ya da çok ciddi
bir hastalığa sahipsinizdir daha da en
kötü de ise o sizin başınıza gelmiştir
ne yapmış olduğunuz bu şekilde
bu duygularımızdan kaçmış olduğunuz
Çünkü Beynimiz bu şekilde işliyor kötü
bir duygu yaşadığımızda zihnimiz bizi
oradan uzaklaştırmak için oradan oraya
savurur durur Erk Kötü bir durum yaşadım
ya boş ver ya değersizliği Bak burada
Kanser olmak var bak vücuduna bir bak
bak kalbinde bir tekliyor Sen boş Burada
yersizliği burada takıldı çünkü Beynimiz
bizim o kötü duygu da bu şekilde
uzaklaştırıyor
duygularımızla mücadele etmek yerine
onlarla dost olmalıyız arkadaşlar
kaygına dostol korkunla dost ol şimdi
çocukluğumuzda hiç plastik bir topu
denizin altında tutmaya çalıştınız mı
O çok zor güç gerektiren bir şey
bastırıyor Sun böyle yan tarafta
arkadaşların oyun oynuyorlar aklında
hala orada ama sen hala topu bastırmakla
uğraşıyorsun şimdi dönelim günümüze bu
top Senin duyguların Burada da yitip
giden hayatın var aslında o topu oradan
bıraksan Tube etrafında dönse Heyecanın
Kaygın korkun burada dönsün dursun Sen
hayatını yaşamaya devam et ne bu şekilde
hayatı kaçıracaksın ne de güç
arayacaksın Hayatında en az bir kere
psikologa gitmiş kişiler görebilir miyim
Seda salmış Vav bayağı varmış seyahat
almış olmaz bile yeterli diyecektim ki
oh yani bayağı fazlaymış Peki
Kendi atar mısınız
arkadaşlar o kadar zor bir şey bir
başardınız gibi psikologa giderek seans
olarak duygularınızla yüzleşmeyi
Seçtiğiniz Çünkü bizim Seyahat bu
dediğimiz yani travmaları çözdüğümüz yer
sanıldığının aksine iyi hissetmeye yeri
değil iyileşme yeridir insanlar zanneder
ki ben Bir psikologa gideyim mutlu
oluyorum Kendimi iyi İstediğim Hayır
berbat istedi olarak kendilerini
olduğundan daha kötü çıkıyorlar oradan
hatta Benim meslektaşım Danışanın
migrenine geçirdi kadın birkaç gün sonra
aramış bunu demiş ki hocam sen bana ne
yaptın ya migrenim bana geri ver Hoca
demiş Ne oldu yataktan çıkamıyorum
Depresyona girdim Kendimi çok kötü
hissediyorum karnım ağrıyor midem
bulanıyor Ne oldu burada bugüne kadar
halının altına süpürmüşler olduğu bütün
travmaları korkuları kaygıları gün
yüzüne çıktı travmalı ile yüzleşti Bu
arada travma derken lütfen Savaş göç
felaket gibi çok büyük felaketler
hakkımızda gelmesin küçük Taylor
dediğimiz değersizlik yetersizlik
başarısızlık duyguları bir araya gelerek
büyük TL sebep verirler ve biz onlarla
uğraş ve yine aynı ta ki çok büyük bir
travma ile uğraşıyor muşuz gibi zaman
alır yetersizlik duygusu şuradan
tanıyabilirsiniz o duygu Size geldiğimde
her şeyi planlarsınız plan plan plan
plan plan hep bir mükemmele ulaşma
çabası Hep bir plan ajandalar güzel
renkli kalemler postitler hep planda
kalır Bunlar barat almayı düşünen bir
kişi düşünelim atanınca mutlu olacağım
diyor soruyorsun atan Mutlu musun ya
işte bir evleneyim mutlu olacağım diyor
tamam diyorsun evleniyor muradına eriyor
tekrar soruyorsun şimdi mutlu musun
enişte bir çocuğum olsa o zaman mutlu
olacağım diyor mutluluğu hep bir şeylere
bağlı hep bir şeylere bağlı olduğu için
sonsuza dek L böyle gidiyordu na parka
giden iki çocuk düşünelim Bir yol
boyunca Baba ne kadar kaldı baba istek
Ben çok sıkıldım Buradan sonra nereye
gideceğiz Ne yapacağız gibi sürekli
babasının sorular soruyordu ya da
Gittiğinde de sıkılıyor ve eve dönmek
istiyor diğer çocukta da parka gidene
kadar Ah ne kadar farklı binalar var Aha
çok güzelmiş bu da değişik ağaçlar
varmış gibi yolun tadını çıkarıyor
lunaparka Gittiğinde de tadını çıkarıyor
ilk bahsettiğim çocuk haz odaklı yaşıyor
diyebiliriz diğer çocuksa değer odaklı
yaşıyor ver odaklı yaşayan kişiler o
kadar mutlu ki anın tadını çıkarırlar
şimdi anın tadı demişken Aa tadı nasıl
çıkarılır biliyor musunuz
benim masamın üzerinde duran bir tane
çiçek var Ben bazen bunu haz odaklı
yaşayan danışanları mı veriyorum diyorum
ki bakar mısın bakalım ne isteyeceksin
veriyorum bakıyor ne istedim hiçbir şey
diyor Tamam diyorum hani biraz daha
duygulara gir biraz daha Hisset bakıyor
tekrar böyle
Yok Böyle Bir Şey Gelmiyor Gözlerini
kapat hissetmeye çalışıyorum çiçeğin
yapraklarını dokunuyor toprağına
dokunuyor diyor ki ağlıyor yaprakları
çok güzelmiş çok güzel kokuyormuş ya
toprağa biraz nemli ymiş yeni yeni fark
ediyor bunları yine boş gibi dolaşalım a
kahve ikram ettim dedim ki kahve nasıl
değil güzel ve tekrar sordum kahve nasıl
o cam çok güzel olmuş sanki ben kahve
nasıl olduğunu merak ediyormuşum gibi
üçüncü kere sorduğumda kahve nasıl
dediğimde o sırada gözlerini kapattı ve
dedi ki hocam biraz acılık var bu
kahvede şimdi o kahvede her zaman bu
acılık vardı Ama o bugüne kadar hiç bunu
fark etmemişti işte değersizlik
yetersizlik başarısızlık duygularıyla
uğraşmakta İnsanlar bunları farkına
varamıyor ve anın tadını kanun tadını
hiç bir şekilde çıkarmıyorlar geçmişim
pişmanlığı geleceğin korkusu derken
maalesef böyle anları çok fazla
kaçırıyoruz Ben hala kimi zamanlar
yetersizlik duygusu hissettiğimi
söylemiştim o zamanlar sığındığım
Gerçekten güç aldım çok güçlü bir
kişinin sözü var Onu sizlerle paylaşmak
istiyorum da muhtaç olduğun Kudret
damarlarındaki Asil kanda mevcuttur
Teşekkür ederiz
[Müzik]
biz o